is there a god neuron
is there a belief neuron
is there so through this methodology of
optogenetics can you start
getting
to like where
a belief
begins or an idea begins
and especially looking at the strongest
of our beliefs
maybe beliefs of love and hate but
religious belief into some something
like really
grand
on the the grandest of scale yeah
neuroscience
and
uh neurology point us a little bit uh we
don't have an answer to that but yeah a
lot of these questions i'm going to ask
you there's no good answer but they're
you're providing the tools that give us
hope to find the answer one day yeah and
we have early clues so for example
when patients with epilepsy
have
uh experiences of religiosity as part of
their seizure or the aura before their
seizure
very often those are uh in the in the
temporal lobe
in these parts of the brain that are
at the side
and so that's initial
clue
there are also
parts of the brain that
are involved in the
definition of the self uh and defining
the borders or boundaries of the self
and
we know this is just some experiments
that we did in my lab there's a part of
the brain where if there's a rhythm
uh
of a particular type you can cause a
separation of the sense of
self
from the sense of the body
what's normally bound up and unitary we
normally think of ourselves and our body
is pretty tightly bound up together
those can be separated it turns out we
can't take that for granted and there
are certain conditions certain patterns
of activity in
one part of the brain called the
retrosplenial cortex where you can
actually separate those two out and so
if you think about
these very big questions
you know what is
where are the origins of
religiosity where how do we define the
boundaries of who we are relative to
others and to the world
how do we link
our self to our body and how can that
become separated these are actually
believe it or not now
accessible uh and rigorously and
quantitatively so we did an experiment
with optogenetics where we provided this
abnormal rhythm
to this particular part of the mouse
brain and we saw this separation of
detection of a stimulus
and
caring about it so that's that's like
stimulating something about the mouse
brain that affects these
neurons that give the conception of self
so you're able to dissociate
the experience from the impact of the
experience unto you that's right exactly
right so like these are the goals of
meditation
uh these are the goals whenever i get
drunk pretty much effective i mean
that's not a scientific statement just
an experiential anecdotal one um also
psychedelics seek to this
uh to attain this kind of state that's
so interesting well you mentioned
psychedelics you know dmt and 5meo dmt
these these create this religious
experience this connection people
describe them as a strong connection to
god
in theory these are accessible with with
modern methods we we now that we have
these rich recording methods we can
explore what are the
precise
millisecond resolution cellular
resolution
brainwide
manifestations of these altered states
so like you could uh look at an altered
state like an on dmt
record it across many people
and then from there see where do these
experiences originate in the brain in
terms of single neurons
and then
uh how do they how do they propagate and
interact with everything else and if
there's some kind of
uh common signal like how do you
narrow down the set of neurons that are
responsible for particular experience or
for a particular behavioral effect yeah
here's where optogenetics is so useful
because anytime you give an agent like a
you know an agent like
ketamine or pcp which we used for our
dissociation experiments that i was
mentioning or you have a psychedelic
lsd or dmt
for this
altered perceptual state
if you
if you give either of those these
change everything across the brain okay
so just just the fact that you maybe
give them to a mouse let's say or
eventually to a human
you won't know
yet which cells to hone in on as the
causal
players in all this just by recording
the activity but then
what we found is that optogenetics
providing a causal pattern of activity
guided
by what you see
can let you test hypotheses and we saw
this rhythm
with ketamine and pcp for dissociation
and then we said okay
let's test what's causal
we came in and provided that rhythm we
tried a few different things but only
one
of the causal tests we tried actually
caused the behavioral dissociation
and so that's how we home in on what
actually and is it repeatable once you
see the cause so like that's one
definition of causality is like you try
and repeats across different mice and
all that kind of stuff exactly
and so you could do that for dmt you
could do that for the like the really
fascinating mind expanding uh uh
thank you
thank you so the meme for people just
listening this is again another
disagreement between freud and and uh
uh carl jung religion and spirituality
this is the i guess the ring scene from
uh
lord of the rings religion spirituality
freud says cast it into the fire destroy
it
carl jung says
no so so for people who don't know
sergey is
the slavic lord of the meme thank you i
appreciate that
so what we're talking about so do there
is i mean i think a connection between
gmt and religious experiences or some of
these psychedelics do you think it's
possible to
sort of stimulate religious experiences
so religious experiences are one of the
most deep kind of experiences and so
here you could
first understand
where they originate how they propagate
to the brain
and then to stimulate them
and so this is and these that can happen
in
people who had no predisposition um
you know people who who are
you know as agnostic or atheistic as
you'd like they can have these they can
feel connected to god in these in these
states
now to be clear i'm not advocating these
we don't know what's safe uh in human
beings but we definitely have not yet
but we definitely can do these
experiments in in mice and that was
already
very productive in understanding
dissociation so we can already imagine
making headway on these methods
and then you know i had a and this this
does map on to the non
psychedelic human experience i had a
patient
who's actually described in in the book
projections this was the patient that's
in the mania chapter the bipolar chapter
here was a guy who had never
had a psychiatric illness or symptom in
his life he was a retirement age
gentleman
and
nobody in his family either so no family
history no personal history of any
psychiatric illness and he had never
been religious particularly before
either certainly no no passionate you
know uh type of religion
but he not through any psychedelic or
drug he he had a stressful experience
actually a post 9 11
change in how he was thinking and he was
pushed into a mania a manic state
revealing that he had bipolar never
before known in this case in this person
and his mania his elevated state and
bipolar included this profound
religiosity he
which he had never had before and he was
he was you know
preaching in a in a
elevated you know vigorous way to his
family and so this this state
can be created in people
even late in life who had no
predisposition for it and know even
without a neurochemical so
there's the the the causality of that is
very interesting to explore how did the
the manic state
unleash this religiosity but you see
that in other realms of of psychiatry to
ocd
can manifest as religiosity also you can
take people who never really had a
a
religion never played a powerful role in
their life but then when their
obsessive compulsive symptoms become
severe they can manifest in this i think
i'm with that group some i'm a bit ocd
we have uh
there's i think these subreddits uh when
there's oddly satisfying things
so there's certain things that are
really satisfying to my ocd and my mild
ocd i think it's pretty much a religious
experience
so i understand that there's it
if it's not direct it's at least uh
rhymes so maybe can you speak to the
sergey is probably uh desperately
scrambling to pull up oddly satisfying
thank you people can check it out
themselves it is as as the subreddit
promises oddly satisfying
you